tous les ans on vous raconte une
histoire qui a un élève dans votre lycée
ou dans le lycée de quelqu'un d'autre
qui a eu 20 sur 20 parce qu'au sujet
qu'est ce que l'audace il a répondu en
une phrase c'est ça il a rendu sa copie
et il a eu 20 sur 20 cette histoire elle
est fausse j'ai essayé de me poser la
question mais depuis quand cette rumeur
elle existe alors c'est extrêmement
difficile de remonter à l'origine mais
on a une trace à ses anciennes
c'est dans un film en 1978 est un film
qui s'appelle le pion c'est un film
français qu'il ya pas mal de succès à
l'époque et dans ce film c'est pas une
épreuve de philo c'est une épreuve de
français il ya un élève qui fait cette
réponse à un prof
qu'est ce que le risque à l'époque et il
a non pas 20 sur 20 c'est marrant parce
que la rumeur a évolué avec le temps
il a 18 sur 20 alors pourquoi est ce
qu'elle marche autant pourquoi elle
prend autant en fait d'abord ce qui est
étonnant c'est qu'elle a pris beaucoup
avant les réseaux sociaux on est
toujours que c'est les réseaux sociaux
qui permettent aux rumeurs de se
diffuser
ben là c'est bien avant puisque je vous
parle de la plus de 40 ans qu'elle
existe cette rumeur certains me disent
même que dans les années 60 on la
raconte est déjà donc c'est même bien
avant les réseaux sociaux alors pourquoi
elle marche autant elle marche le temps
parce que je crois que sa rencontre
plusieurs choses d'abord c'est peut-être
que le rêve de chacun d'entre nous que
d'arrivées être plus malin que le prof
plus malin que le sujet et avec un coup
de génie d'obtenir la meilleure note
possible
il ya aussi peut-être une autre idée qui
est celle que finalement en philo c'est
une épreuve un peu à part les notes
c'est un peu n'importe quoi parfois et
on peut imaginer d'avoir un 20 sur 20
sur un coup de poker
sur une idée j'ai retrouvé un truc assez
rigolo c'était il ya 25 ans en france il
ya une fille au concours général de
philosophie qui est l'épreuve la plus
difficile que les élèves peuvent choisir
ou pas de faire quand ils sont en
première ou en terminale
la fille en philo est là le deuxième
prix du concours général
donc c'est vraiment une fille super
forte en philo qui a plein de culture
qui sait rédigé qui sait faire une
dissertation et une semaine après il ya
sa note de bac philo qui arrive est la
fille à la main sur 20 je prétends suez
n'aboutit qu'à de vrais marque très
souvent proche du non sens et à tout le
moins accepta
absolument aucune connaissance
d'ailleurs ces fonds je fais des
citations je parlais de niche de platon
de rousseau pour moi c'est la n1 c'était
à 25 ans un sur 20 les journalistes y
réfléchissent avec les regardons ferreux
corriger la copie est en fait un nouveau
prof de philo dit qu'en fait ça vaut
beaucoup plus que ça et c'est
intéressant parce que pour plein des
lèvres la philo c'est pas une matière
comme les autres c'est une matière où
vraiment on peut briller alors qu'on est
mauvais toute l'année et surtout pour
beaucoup d'élèves
c'est une matière il n'y a pas besoin de
la réviser ça se réalise pas comme les
maths comme l'histoire géo ou comme ou
comme le français en première avec un
peu de talent on peut être plus malin
que les preuves et c'est aussi pour ça
que ça a pris
mais aussi cette histoire elle prend
parce que comme toutes les rumeurs
quand on la raconte on dit jamais je
connais quelqu'un qui connaît quelqu'un
qui connaît quelqu'un qui connaît
quelqu'un qui a eu sa on raccourcit à
chaque fois on dit dans mon lycée
je connais quelqu'un qui a eu cette
histoire
et du coup aux permanences elle est
réactivée et comme en plus c'est une
histoire universelle c'est pas un tel
qu'avec cette note c je connais
quelqu'un eh bien on peut en permanence
la raconter comme le bac philo n'a pas
disparu depuis des décennies et des
décennies on peut continuer à raconter
cette histoire qui existent en
permanence malgré et c'est quand même
assez marrant des dénégations complète
il ya des dizaines d'articles de presse
et même cette vidéo elle le dit où on
dit c'est une rumeur
et pourtant je peux vous dire que malgré
tous les articles
et malgré cette vidéo cette année et
l'année prochaine et l'année encore
d'après il y aura des gens qui vous
diront dans mon lycée
je connais quelqu'un qui est tombé sur
qu'est-ce que l'audace qui a dit c'est
ça et qui a eu 20 sur 20